what is it what is it for you performed
in a seafood festival I mean what should
show you or know about was it crap I had
a crab fest
and it beginning the stand-up comedy
you're not you're not performing in in
luxury
you know venues whoever they feel that
they can build the stage and make money
as where you going
so there was a crab fest comedians
talent people cracking prayer literally
the frustration that comes from not
being able to open a crack
you're not funny at the same time look
at you here I remember hearing a woman's
older lady who was like she was cracking
crash cuz this is how you Craig Craig
[Music]
tell a joke and a joke doesn't work and
I remember this lady just gone how a
much rather be booth disappointment her
voice she said baby it was I own no baby
[Applause]
with my choice of life you know look at
the hardship that I went through his
help help build me into the person I am
today right I can take so much but I've
been through it all I was I was hit in
the face with a buffalo wings there's no
food
it was it was a it was actually a male
strip club they shut down for comedy for
the first half it was ladies in there
and you know it's just supposed to be us
performing for these women that were
roused up first thing I got on stage
when they introduced me and as they like
pull it out I know who's got kids I
start trying to merge it's a kid
materials do from the back he's like
that's enough just do a buffalo wing
sauce
a woman with a deep voice I was like who
throw it who if at the end of that I'm a
man I'm a man first don't disrespect me
he stood up he was like I did it not
I can't de plata just taking my clothes
off
[Applause]
you